[Applause]
ross you have the next story and i have
to just put my personal investment stamp
on it it might be my favorite story of
the month oh okay well okay well listen
to this okay who here has spent time or
energy worrying about what someone else
might be thinking about you anybody
guilty about that well if you're one of
those people like us i have good news
for you psychology today reports hey no
one is thinking about you
congratulations
we suffer so much worrying about what
other people think but experts say we
chronically overestimate how much they
think about us and we always think it's
like way harsher than what people are
actually thinking researchers have
studied this uh erica booth calls it the
likability gap studies show if you pair
two people for a conversation afterwards
they always think the other person was
more interesting than that person
probably found them think about that how
many times after a date or a meeting
you're in the car the train you're
thinking like why didn't i say that they
probably think i'm an idiot why and that
person is just thinking like what's for
lunch you know they're not thinking
about you yes and i'm someone who really
goes for it i go for a lot of jokes and
i'm kind of like a big personality so
sometimes i really have those oh my god
like
what did i just do moments
but the calming soothing
humility
to hear from psychology today a renowned
medical journal periodical that people
are not sitting there obsessing about
you the way you're obsessing about them
obsessing about you yes this is such
good news it's like
forget about it yeah i actually loved
this motion
forget about it about it all right well
next up we love to uh take brand new
products for a spin and today we've got
one and these are from your suggestions
that you write in it's time for drew's
reviews hey
okay
all right today's review is suggested
from none other than paula rose thank
you paula we're trying the cheeseburger
burrito from the mad food scientist at
trader joe's so it's apparently the
perfect marriage between two foods the
burrito and the cheeseburger yeah i'm
holding a burrito but it smells like
secret sauce from a hamburger you know
i'm talking like that thousand island
pickley beefy cheesy yeah
well should we should we try it yeah
cheers
cheers okay
oh um
oh my god
you know what it tastes like
a cheeseburger burrito
it's interesting because i'm getting all
the goodness of the cheeseburger
um
like
forward you know how it's like bun and
condiments and then you get to the meat
this is like almost working the inside
out like it's burgerford
then cheese and then a little bit of
like that flowery dough you want but not
too much trader joe's you've done it
again
well
it's time to rate it roxy how many stars
out of five do you give it
one two three four five stars trader
joe's
oh my god
[Music]
you